okay so that you you touched on this
idea of the destruction of the work of
art you know and one of the things I
really liked about reading Nietzsche was
his discussion of rosante mall right of
resentment and and it seems to me that a
tremendous amount of the motive power
that drives the postmodernist let's call
it it's not a revolution transformation
seems to me to be driven by resentment
about virtually anything that has any
well what would you say any merit of
competence or aesthetic quality and I
don't know if that's it seems to me that
that's partly rooted in the academics
disdain for the business world which i
think is driven by their relative
economic inequality because most people
who are as intelligent as academics are
from a pure IQ point of view make more
money in the private sphere and so I
think that drives some of it but there
also seems to be this there's a
destruction an aim for destruction of
the of the aesthetic quality of the of
the literary or artistic work its
reduction to nothing but some kind of
power game and then in surrounding that
the reduction of everything to something
that approximates a power game which
which I can't help but identifying with
with jealousy and resentment as a
fundamental motivator does that seem
reasonable to you these professors who
allege that art is nothing but an
ideological movement by one elite okay
against the against another group right
these people are Philistines okay
they're Philistines they're middlebrow
hopelessly middlebrow they think they
have no sense of beauty they have no
sense of the aesthetic now Marxism does
indeed assert this okay but Markson
tries to reconfigure the universe in
terms of materialism it sees it does not
recognize any kind of spiritual
dimension now I'm an atheist but I see
the great world religions as enormous
works of art okay as the as the is the
best way to understand the universe in a
man's place in them I find them enormous
ly moving that they're like enormous
poems right and I would I have called
for the true revolution okay would have
been okay
make the core curriculum of world
education the world the great religions
of the world I feel that is the only way
to achieve an understanding and it's
also a way to to present the aesthetic
okay because I feel that that that the
real sixties vision was about exultation
elevation cosmic consciousness okay
I all of these things they were rejected
they buy these by these midgets okay
intellectual midgets who seized onto
Lacan Derrida and Foucault right it's an
and I career has been in the art school
so I'm an my entire career beginning of
anything college so I represent a
challenge to this from the perspective
of art it is an absolute nonsense okay
as post structuralism maintains that
reality is mediated by language by words
everything that we can know including
gender it's absolutely madness because
I'm teaching students whose majors are
ceramics okay or dance okay or or a jazz
musicians who understand reality in
terms of the body it's a sensory active
activation so they now that they see
what happens something was going on in
the art world as well I identify with
Andy Warhol in pop art okay that was
what was going on during my years in
college everything about Andy Warhol was
like wow admiration wow what happened
immediately after that in the arts 1970s
okay was this collapse into a snide sort
of post-modernism also this happened in
the art world
right right and it was an utter
misunderstanding of culture it seems to
me by that movement in the art world
that is oppositional art in my view is
dead okay he's been and this in what
post-modernism is isn't it a pathetic
attempt to continue the old heroism of
the avant-garde the avant-garde was
genuinely heroic from the early 19th
century okay we're talking about you
know where the corbeil the realists you
know we're talking about Monet and the
impressions people who genuinely
suffered for their radical ideas and
knew their innovations and so on going
right down to to Picasso and down to a
tube Jackson Pollock who like was who
truly suffered to pay for Nia for his
art it was only after his death okay
that suddenly
market was created for abstract art pop
art killed the avant-garde the idea that
the avant-garde continues is an absolute
delusion of the contemporary art world
which feels that they must attack attack
attack challenge okay they knew the
simplistic beliefs of the hoi polloi
okay somehow the artists what excuse me
okay
from the moment okay Andy Warhol went
through and embraced the popular media
in brick instead of having the
opposition to it the serious arts of had
okay that was the end of oppositional
art okay so we have been going on now
for 50 years the post-modernism and a
khadeem is hand in hand with with the
stupidity and infantilism that
masquerades as you know as important art
at galleries everywhere this incredible
incredible you know it's mechanism of
contemporary art way of pushing things
that are that are so hopelessly
derivative that it with this idea that
once again that the art world somehow
superior view of reality